jesus loves me this I know for the Bible
tells me so little one to him belong
they are weak but he is strong you work
all cotton I still believe that the
world needs to get saved
[Applause]
soldier my comfort and my joy is that
you're here to lead the way
[Music]
after the black rubber Oh going in the
wrong direction
[Music]
don't smoke do it what does it matter
already one thinks matters to me people
have been saying that I stopped
believing in hell I heard a voice say
everyone's already saved oh no you can't
just rewrite the by not rewriting
anything I'm just rereading it you speak
the Word of God in this church why don't
you call me you owe me that much
[Music]
sassy Sun you need to consider
everything you're putting at risk and
not just for yourself you don't need to
be saying you don't know that know that
you want proof it wasn't a voice you
heard half our congregation walking out
that was it
either you're with me or you're not
become the talents we all wall-to-wall
but it's false that when you pitch
[Music]
are you certain it was not his voice you
heard
I've never been more sure of anything in
my life and I'm not backing down
[Music]
you
[Music]
you